(audience cheering)
Hello!
Hi!
Isn't this so crazy?
So crazy, I can't believe this.
I know, it's like--
I feel like I'm on Star Trek or something,
like we're in two different states.
I know, and yet we're right here next to each other.
We could sort of like high five.
I know.
Which, in COVID times,
is about all we could really do sort of anyway.
Gosh, Zoe, I remember when we went to a dinner one time,
many years ago, and we were both literally kidless.
We hadn't had our children yet.
I know it's crazy, isn't it?
I mean, ya think, now we have kiddos.
You have two girls?
I have two girls, Olive, eight, Frankie, six.
And you have Elsie, five and Charlie, three.
Exactly!
(squeals)
Now I hear that Elsie is a cat fan.
Yeah, she's like obsessed with cats, obsessed.
She loves cats.
And what's really funny is that,
I'll be, she likes anything sparkly.
So if I wear something that has sparkles on it,
I'll be like, well, she'll say, "I love that mommy."
And I say like, "When you grow up, I'll save it for you.
"You can have it."
And she goes, "But I'm gonna be a cat when I grow up."
(audience laughing)
Oh, yeah, oh totally, I forgot, yeah.
You'll be a cat, so we'll cut it down to cat size
and make it a cat sweater.
Well, this is perfect considering it's craft week,
we could fashion her a collar and, like a little--
Kitty ears.
Yes, yes!
And Charlie, I heard, is very obsessed with dinosaurs.
Yup. Loves dinosaurs.
He pretends to be a dinosaur all the time.
'Cause I'm in the two girl club,
and I just--
Yeah.
I've never experienced what it's like to be
with a little boy, and other than like cats and dinosaurs,
what is the difference between boys and girls?
I'm so fascinated.
It is really fascinating.
My daughter is extremely independent and kind of catlike
in personality, like affection's on her terms.
She wants to hug you, she'll hug you.
She doesn't, she'll be like, "I don't want a hug right now."
My son, always up for a hug, always up for snuggling.
Very, like, "Mommy, I love you 'cause you're so beautiful."
You know, Frankie and Olive are the same way.
Maybe it's an age thing, because Olive is extremely,
like it's all on her terms, she's stubborn, she's brave.
She's super cool, and Frankie is like the touchiest,
coziest, every morning she crawls in my lap
and I just go, "Do you want to come back?
"Do you want to get back inside?"
And she's like, "Mm-hmm."
And walks me to the door and then kisses me the whole way.
Today, Olive was just like, don't, you know, it's so true.
Maybe it's like an age thing or maybe it's us as parents.
I mean--
Yeah, I mean,
they're definitely both super sweet,
but my daughter's just a little bit more, she's total boss.
She's like, you do this.
She yesterday, she kept going, "But I'm a director.
"I'm the director."
(audience laughing)
And I'm like, I don't know,
they were playing something and she'd decided
that she was the director and he was like the actor.
I'm like, "You have to give the actor some agency,
"they have to be able to like make their own choices."
(audience laughing)
I mean, your family is such a creative family.
Emily, your sister is an amazing actress.
Your mom is an actress.
And your dad, I had the pleasure and privilege
of working with very briefly.
But I was so excited to work with the Caleb Deschanel,
because he also is not only
one of the best cinematographers ever,
and then he also did one of the most beautiful films
ever made is "The Black Stallion."
And I often watch it with my girls.
And the footage on the beach, it's like an art exhibit.
Every time you watch it, it's not like a movie.
Beautiful movie, yeah, yeah.
We don't take the time in movies anymore
to just show poetry.
I think it's like,
and I like doing movies like this where there's just time.
There's not like constant cutting.
There's time to tell the story, they take their time.
I think people almost get nervous
if you're not constantly cutting,
but it's really nice to just see a shot play out.
I think one of the new school movies
that was a perfect transition was "500 Days of Summer."
I mean that to me is just a modern classic.
So fun to make, that movie was so fun to make.
So yeah, we had the best time.
I mean--
Don't you feel like,
if you have a good time making a movie, it's usually good?
This is just my experience.
If I have a good time doing something,
it usually turns out well.
If I don't have a good time, it's normally not a good movie.
Well, Jerry Lewis always said that what the emulsion
of the film is picking up in the room is what gets
projected out to people when they see it.
So, I do believe that.
And "Elf," I have to just, I love "Elf" so much.
And by the way, how fun to be in a movie that
gets seen every year.
That's fun, yeah, for sure.
I always like get people who watch it every year,
and it's such an honor to, you know.
Did you guys have fun making that movie, 'cause that
just seems like
Yeah.
Oh yeah, well, Will is so nice and so kind, and just like,
I was so young when I made that movie and I was like,
it was my first big romantic lead role.
And I was so nervous
and Will is just such a sweet person and welcoming and kind.
And I remember seeing him on set
and he was just nice to every single person.
And I remember that, I love to see somebody who
takes the time to be kind to everybody.
And I just really admire that
and always remember what a sweet person he is.
Yeah, it is.
And was at that time, too.
It's incredibly important, oh, gosh.
Okay, well, I heard you're into miniatures.
I'm obsessed with miniatures.
We made a little something for you.
And I'm just so excited because my daughter Frankie,
her nickname is the miniature enthusiast.
So we made you a tiny little Drew mug.
(audience laughing)
It's so cute!
So that you can...
I mean, literally, I'll clean it
before I send it.
I love it so much.
Zooey, I can't wait to do some crafts with you.
I can't wait.
(bright music)